le
jeu ne suis pas me dire yale victoire de
la pluie dernière pourtant ce temps ne
peut pas tout comme des débutants
moi j'ai dans des fêtes j'espère voir
peut-être même si l'histoire gelé déjà
pas trop fait et le fait c'est plus fort
que moi
c'est comme lapointe
x y at-il du mal
qu'ils font pas de soins
ici ou là
je marque
au
ps
milite gens dans des gares
attendent d'être un retard
les yeux ce pas c'est le décembre coude
invisible par quelque chose
qui se cacherait derrière
mais on soulève peillon ce soit dans le
même
on a peur
on est pas mal
en consolation
pour gagner bas
non ici ou là qui sent
encore lui
au plus ancien
jusqu'au bout
ciel
vous regardez anciens jours
la ville où je te tour
les essuie glaces sont à balayer tout ça
les traces
un vieux mac assad
qui parle vivante que la ville
d'aujourd'hui si lointaine tout mélanger
temps
au milieu là
des enfants pour cent
si la vie nous tue
beige qu'elle continue
apparu
pour lui monsieur
à
yoplait ciel
mais
oh
monsieur